they were hoping they could prevent
Kyrgyzstan former leader from being
arrested but after two days standoff
security forces didn't want to wait any
longer a police officer was killed and
70 of the former president's supporters
injured in the ensuing clashes this one
says that mbf was in the van with her
and they were both arrested it all
started on Wednesday when a tumbe have
greeted crowds outside of his home near
Bishkek shots rang out police attempted
to arrest him then but his supporters
rushed to his defense after the fair to
rest he urged people to protest in the
capital we will start a demonstration
we're going to go to the White House and
we'll head an indefinite demonstration
because the authorities need to stop
this mayhem a tambay of who is in office
from 2011 to 2017 was wanted as a
witness in a criminal case he refused
questioning three times leading to his
arrest but some say the police didn't
need to be so heavy-handed these
youngsters aileth or the president said
that at mbf needs to give a witness
statement so what is a witness statement
it doesn't mean that he needs to take
over by storming or using security
forces but a Tembe of didn't get support
in Parliament where the president
condemned his use of violence against
the police
former president Atambayev and his
supporters have committed serious crimes
against Kyrgyz Republic he has violated
the law by putting resistance and using
arms during the legitimate action by
police who came to arrest him since
kyrgyzstan is independence in 1991 two
presidents have been deposed by
uprisings ethnic tensions and high
poverty rates continue to challenge the
country there are now fears that the
former Soviet nation will be thrown into
turmoil with protesters now turning
their anger on the current President
Laura Burton manly al-jazeera